we all remember when jesse smellet was
viciously attacked in chicago had a
noose placed around his neck just barely
summoned the fortitude to keep hold of
his subway sandwich during the assault
well three years later smallett's
attacker has finally been brought to
justice
he did not take the news well
you are fined
25 000 which is the maximum fine
and you will spend the first 150 days of
your sentence in the cook county jail
and that will start today right here
right now do you have any questions
no i would just like to say to your
honor that i am
i am not
suicidal that's what i was practicing
i'm not suicidal okay i am not
suicidal i am innocent and i am not
suicidal
if i did this then it means that i stuck
my fist in the fears of black americans
in this country for over 400 years and
the fears of the lgbtq community your
honor i respect you and i respect the
jury but i did not do this and i am not
suicidal and if anything happens to me
when i go in there
i did not do it to myself and you must
all know that
i respect you your honor i respect your
decision
jail time
i am not suicidal
the most surprising part of the
sentencing was finding out that jesse
smallette has incriminating information
on the clintons that i'm not suicidal
was the cry of a man just waiting for
hillary to walk in with the pillow but
the next most surprising thing about the
sentencing was that smollett is going to
jail at all
i had just assumed that he'd get off the
hook like every other well-connected
politically correct leftist who plays
the right victim cards
but jesse will go to jail and he should
because his crime was not just against
himself
and his crime was not just against the
chicago pd
it was a crime against half of this
country a crime against mega country
which he defamed as a racist lynch mob
he perpetrated a fraud on one half of
this country about the other half
it's the same fraud that the liberal
establishment perpetrates every day when
it calls us deplorable and irredeemable
jesse smellette just took it a little
bit further and made the mistake of
casting nigerian homosexuals to play
anti-gay white supremacists so he got
caught and despite repeated attempts by
the establishment to let him off the
hook now he's paying the price
good
justice for jesse means just a teensy
tiny little bitty bit of justice for the
rest of us too
i'm so glad you liked that clip now
please please ring that bell subscribe
get the notifications and more
importantly even than that head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher
wherever you get your podcasts subscribe
to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review if you wouldn't
mind really appreciate it we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]